you wrote this amazing article called
how to make a movie on 5000 and I have
here sort of nine points nine how to's
and the first one you say is be
realistic in the script writing process
yeah exactly like I I remember you know
I've been to readings of scripts and
like they there's there's oh there's
like you know we're at the baseball game
and people are having a Pierre watching
the baseball games like wait
didn't you think like you're gonna have
to rent the stadium and the base you
know you can't people don't think about
realistically about about what you can
and can't film so I said I think have
only trying to have a maximum of four
people on the scene shoot it in a
location you can get for free and yeah
try and keep it simple simplicity
simplicity okay sounds good and then
number two rent don't buy your camera
yeah that's kind of interesting I'm
halfway but about that in the sense that
they're the super high-end three
thousand dollar camera I can it's you're
not gonna be able to resell it it to
make your money back it's better to rent
those super high-end ones you know for
your film shoot but like a camera like
this Canon that we're filming on right
now which shoots an HD which are amazing
with these lenses that they're they're
essentially a still camera that shoot HD
movies they look fantastic they look so
good and they're though some of them are
around like 500 bucks so if you're if
you're a filmmaker and you like to film
and you think you're gonna be doing a
lot of different stuff you can't really
go wrong with with one of those low end
cameras in your arsenal that's what I
think you say pay your your crew
your small crew exact no freebies ya got
me hopefully you can get a few people
extra that just want to work on a film
if they want to work for free come on up
Lord but your sound guy you gotta
basically pay and your camera guy you
know unless you're like I said you're
you're really into cameras get yourself
a guy on Craigslist who probably charges
like a hundred a day maybe 200 he's got
all the equipment he knows what he's
doing he's fast
get him pay him then he's gonna show up
if you're like intern blah blah blah
you're just you the flake factor just
ramps up you say have an actor supply
most of the wardrobe and props yeah
another key thing obviously you don't
have a a wardrobe person but actors are
their characters they have they have
rooms of wardrobe because they have to
for various auditions therefore if they
get the character you say hey this is
your character bring some stuff in that
you think the character might wear
they're gonna bring in all your stuff
unless it's some weird you know
specialized thing occasion things you
might have to do but most of it should
just be supplied by the actor props to
you and then speaking of actors make
sure you sign a sag ultra low budget
agreement from the screen actors though
exactly i think sag has made it easy and
affordable for filmmakers to use
professional actors for a reasonable
price you know if you do sell the movie
beyond the theatrical expert the
exposition the theatrical if it goes DVD
or internet VOD you you are going to
have to pay some residuals but it will
be you know a small percentage of your
low-budget film that technically has
already
a little bit of money because it costs
you nothing to make so and then you say
get production insurance yeah that is
that is essential for the SAG budget
anyway because you can't hire actors
without the proper insurance but it
helps you out because when you need a
location that maybe you don't quite have
access to personally but I was working
on a film pilot and they were able to
convince a supermarket to let us film
there because hey we've got the
insurance you know we don't have any
money but we got this issue you're not
liable so it can open the doors to any
location that you might need okay and
then you say avoid the financial trap of
writing popular music in tears oh no
rolling stone sofas yes of course no
Rolling Stones know anybody really
that's been on the radio more or less
you know eight people that you know you
know I was lucky cuz I'm a musician
myself I could use most of my own music
but that's all that stuff is gonna run
you thousands and thousands of dollars
you know just just find enough student
filmmaker local bands and bring them
into the mix they'll do it for next
nothing
now number eight has caused a little bit
of controversy and that is edit the film
yourself right yeah that's the thing
that people you can write you can direct
you can act in your own film people
don't really but the second you say you
edited the film they they freaked out
and it's and to me it seems silly as at
the spec especially at the $5,000 level
because a it's learning experience the
whole thing B you're not gonna have the
you're not going to be able to find
somebody to edit your film for you for
free it's it takes hundreds and hundreds
of hours very labor-intensive that's why
they charge that much now you can
do it yourself it might be very hard for
some people at the beginning but you
will learn a tremendous amount and you
know if you stick with it you will be
fine and of course even if you do edit
it yourself
show it to people get feedback you know
it's not it's not a it's not a wind
tunnel or whatever it's you are doing it
in a sense sometimes editing it yourself
because yeah there's no money to do it
you got to just show it to people get
feedback and then go back and edit it
and then last but not least keep the
hour short the shooting days whew and
the food delicious that's that's my
mantra I tried for the great
intervention with the exception of a
couple days it was like four or five
hours especially for the bigger crowd
stuff I was lucky because I was shooting
documentary style and I didn't want to
do a lot of takes because that would
take the realness out of it but with
these little cameras that we got and
they're so good and light you just don't
need like expensive lighting packages or
dollies or any of those stuff it it's
okay to have a wobbly shaky cam every TV
show now you look it's everything is
kind of wool that that's the new thing
check the camera you see that's people
accept that you know so it's you can
move around almost like a still
photographer now on your set and you can
shoot a lot really quickly and you don't
have to change film and you don't have
to so there's no reason to go beyond ten
hours on your say you know that's a
standard movie set is ten hours those
are the big guys you know if you're got
your crew for free you want to make sure
they're fed and they're home at a
reasonable hour and not grumbling or
they're not going to come back the next
day let's switch gears a little bit
let's talk about sort of the unspoken
they call like the elephant in the room
for Los Angeles sort of that Keeping Up
with your peers keeping up with the
Joneses type thing can you talk about
what you've observed for yourself and
also with other people and how does
somebody walk away feeling good about
where they are in life no matter where
they are on sort of the social food
chain um competition is healthy in one
sense and it's it's we're all striving
but that's the thing I've learned I've
worked with you know people that are
superstars I've worked with people that
are no you know no name or whatever
we're also we're all struggling for the
next thing we all have insecurities we
all nobody's life is perfect and it's
like I I think if you're if you're going
into like competition but other than
just a mental checklist for your own
self am i working hard enough Lola if
you're getting like angry and resentful
oh this person is doing this or that's
just gonna bring you grief it's just
it's just everybody is working everybody
is struggling everybody's everybody is
not where they want to be you know so
it's like just remember that and just
just do your best work that you can and
and you'll impress other people